Okay, so you and I know each other,
we've known each other over many years
in similar circles and circumstances.
We've really spoken to each other
like two women, two humans.
And what I didn't know was that
you were staying at Anna Wintour's house,
and that she was a source of consistent check-ins
as well as encouragement for this.
Is this true?
Absolutely true.
You know, the book was her idea.
And to have a friend like Anna,
she really was the first person who called me
right after the 2016 election, and,
when half the country was in mourning over that loss,
and I was so devastated, I was so shattered
and she calls me and said, "We're going to dinner."
And at dinner, she said, "I know what you should do next.
"You should write your story,
"it's a good story and you should write it."
And I wasn't convinced that I would,
I went and talked to Hillary a couple of days later,
she said I should do it.
It took some convincing for me to do it, but I did,
and I'm glad I did.
And it's been incredible therapy.
And being out in the world,
there's something so liberating and empowering about it.
I really enjoyed it.
I'm so excited to know that like Anna Wintour
was there to nurture you.
And she's not the warmest creature,
so I love hearing that this very stoic woman was
what you needed when she was there for you.
Well, she actually gave me the gift of friendship
at a time when I really needed it.
It was in the midst of one of my very difficult periods
in my marriage.
And there was a public demand that I be fired
because I had chosen to stay with my husband
who had been unfaithful to me.
And I, at that moment, had chosen to stay with him.
And I remember we were at this dinner,
and all the headlines were, "Is Hillary gonna fire Huma?"
And in the middle of this dinner, she walks over to me,
as, you know, the cameras are following and says,
"Would you like to have lunch some time?"
And really ever since that moment, pushed me all the time,
was always there if I needed something,
but pushed me to make decisions, to stay true to myself,
to not listen to my detractors.
And I'm really great, I had that with Hillary
and I've had that with Anna,
and I'm just privileged to have two women like that
in my life.
All right, we're talking about really strong women,
huge figures here.
And, Hillary, you know,
HRC as you call her throughout the book.
And she famously made a life choice, a political decision,
a personal decision, and we're putting ourselves out there.
So make no mistake, we've chosen public life.
Yes.
We're not naive about that.
We've made a conscious choice.
Yes.
And is it true that you would go
and talk to her each time a transgression,
as you call it throughout the book,
with Anthony, you would go into her office,
a woman who probably there's no one
who could understand more living in the life,
being a huge political figure.
What were those conversations?
I think one of the greatest gifts,
walking into the White House at 21
during the Clinton administration, I joined this club.
It's a club that comes with lifetime membership
and it's a club called Hillaryland.
And the thing that's amazing about being
in this environment is that it was a workspace
where you walked in and you felt like you were respected
and your work was valued,
and everyone took responsibility for things as a community.
It was very much a sense of support.
So, I would say that it was a place
where as women climbed up the ladders of success,
they did not step on the fingers of the women below them,
but reached the lowest and pull the rest of us up too.
So it was an environment where I was like,
how do we do this job better?
Or you did a great job on that speech.
How's your mother doing?
You should go talk to my allergist.
Happy birthday.
Right.
And Hillaryland was all of those things
because Hillary Clinton is all of those things.
And so, to be part of that community,
I think did help me throughout
obviously the highs in my life
and certainly the lows in my life.
And every time I did have a personal problem,
and it wasn't just in my relationship,
just generally, I'm not feeling well,
my mom is not doing well,
she always approached these conversations as a friend first
and as a boss second.
And the advice she always gave me was,
"I'm here, you do what is right for you."
It was never judgmental,
"And whatever you choose to do, I'm gonna support you."
(upbeat music)